[Music]
ha no you took just love us in la France
this is guns in here welcome to the 51
that we sold of dirty tricks
in this episode I'm going to show you
one of the wonderful tricky line against
Queens gambit accepted which you
definitely want to consider playing in
professional tournament actors the
opening arises after the following model
d 4 d phi c 4 and now black except the
pawn with a d capture c for the main
line ins with Knight to f3 which stopped
ePHI idea by black however in this video
i am going to propose this
straightforward move III so what white
wants to do is he wants to spawn back
with bishop capture c4 and accordingly
black has two famous choices there is a
famous blunder at this position which I
think everybody should know if you up
and become greedy and hang on to this
extra pawn with the move B Phi then he
is seriously asking for the trouble
after the moon in for obviously black
cannot play a 6 so if he wants to hang
on to his extra material then he has to
play c6
but after pawn captures and pawn
captures white has this little move
Queen to f3 which by false on the 7th
move win the peace and in fact the game
now if you open and continue at this
point with Knight to f6 then my
recommendation is you should continue
with Knight to f3 and if you remember I
have covered a trappy line in my chest
trap 19 so if you haven't check it out
I strongly insist you to go through that
video and learn a nasty line against the
move Knight to f6 however in this video
we are going to concentrate on one of
the most other popular choice namely
ePHI here why should capture on c4 and
after pawn captures and pawn captures
yes indeed we have the isolated queen
pawn position but the one which is very
favorable to the white camp the good
point I like about this variation is it
is more about the piece placement and
tactical ideas rather than memorization
of the pieces so for example in the
majority of cases both the side develop
their piece on the natural squares and
afterwards it is all about understanding
of the position and as we will see some
good technical ideas and nice follow ups
here it doesn't matter whether black
continue with Bishop to d6 or Knight f6
let's say in this game black plays
Bishop to d6 first white continue with
Knight to f3 Knight to f6 both decide
castles and now s3 a nice move which
prevents Bishop to g4 idea by black and
accordingly black also play at 6:00
which stop Bishop to g5 idea by white
okay now it's done for the night both
the B Knights comes to the natural
square Knight to c3 Knight to c6 and if
we check out this position in database
this happens in more than thousand times
we have reached one of the most critical
Junction of this variation and here my
recommendation is you should start with
this tricky move Queen to c2 so as you
can see I have highlighted by the arrows
White has a very cunning idea namely he
wants to play Bishop captures at six and
after pawn takes Queen to g6 looks
pretty nasty for the black camp as for
the database the most popular choice by
black is to play Knight to be for
attacking the Queen and after Queen to
be won as I have highlighted over here
black has tried this to moose frequently
in fact Bishop to e6 has been tried in
more than 50 games where c6 has been
tried in 35 games well I must admit that
Bishop to e6 I don't like this move the
simple reason is after Bishop captures
e6 and pawn captures e6 it is a case
where both the side has a mutual
weaknesses but for white it is easy to
get on the ecig spawn where for black it
is very difficult to get the d4 pawn
anyways I have attached a model game in
the PG in which will give you a very
good idea how to exploit the e6 pawn and
in fact go for the win in this video we
are more concentrating on the move c6
which is the second most popular choice
by black in this position Black's idea
is very simple he wants to play Knight
to d5 blockade the d4 pawn and slowly
exchanging the pieces and go into the
endgame where this d4 pawn is a
clear-cut target well yup that's a good
thought except there is a huge problem
in this video namely a shop captures at
6 spam
so suddenly white emerge with an extra
pawn and if black doesn't capture this
Bishop then Queen to g6 as an ostrich
reply so accordingly black has to accept
this piece sacrifice and after that yup
you guessed it it's a queen check and
after King to h8 and Queen captures at 6
if you calculate the material at this
point white has a two point four bishop
but the most important is what has some
lethal attack going on on the black
naked King which is over the board not
easy to stop Black has two choices
amongst them King to g8 is a pretty bad
one the simple reason is after Knight to
g5 the ab7 pawn it's a great target and
black cannot even play in Knight to d5
yes after simple Knight captures defy
the resulting position is quite better
for the wide so as for the engine the
only resource which can save the black
camp is Bishop to a5 so that Bishop is
covering some important squares however
after the following sequence Knight
captures f7 Roop captures f7 Queen to G
Phi check if the King goes to the H file
then the rukon f7 we'll hangs so
accordingly
black king has to go to their fate
square afterwards you get straight yup
very simple Bishop captures f7 King
captures f7 and the move Queen captures
fi after the whole transaction white
obtained a rook and 3-connected passer
which is obviously a great deciding
winning factor okay
so night 2 at 7 is only logical reply
afterwards
Whitey's going to continue with this
forcing sequence Knight to e4 attacking
twice on d6 Bishop and Bishop has to go
to the e7 in order to control the G Phi
square well it looks like white attack
has been stopped and black has
consolidated his position but this is
where our tricky business comes into the
picture as White has this amazing
attacking reply Knight to e5 so as you
can see what is already threatening
Knight captures f7 and accordingly black
has tried this three replies let's see
against each of them how white create of
winning attack the first more I want to
consider is Queen captures d4 which is
pretty bad one even though it looks like
the obvious move attacking two knights
which at first sight looks very
threatening
but after White's next reply Knight
captures f7 the sequence is pretty much
forced we are following a game between
to 2300 + retreat opponent where black
continued with the obvious move rook
captures f7 and after Bishop captures f7
black take the knight on e4 so for a
time being black has three pieces
against a rook and it looks like black
is doing so good right but it is just an
illusion as after why it's next reply
rook a to even attacking to piece so
black responds his force black has to
play Queen to h4 in order to safeguard
his piece but even after this move black
is not out of the world as the simple
Queen captures Queen and Bishop captures
white has this winning move rook to e4
which by force get one of the piece back
and after Bishop to f6 and rook captures
before it turns out that once again we
have the same scenario where black has
this two minor piece against three
connected past one and a rope which is
always going to favor the white camp you
can check out rest of the game in the PG
n which in fact lasts only 31 moves
where white finishes opponent in a stall
the second more I want to consider is
Knight to d5 which was in fact the
original choice of the black camp but
I'm afraid in this variation this is not
the right choice
yes White has this devastating move f4
so idea is very simple white wants to
play Knight to g5 and if black capture
it the invite will be captured with the
upon and which will unleash the attack
on the app seven-pole not to mention
there are some rook lifts idea by white
also in the air so accordingly the base
response goes here with Bishop to fi not
only supporting at 7 but hitting the
knight on e4 ok no issues we are going
to play Knight to g5 attacking twice on
f7 and giving black only two choices if
black take this Knight then the simplest
is you take back with the pawn attacking
the bishop and after Bishop to g6 White
has few nice continuation but amongst
all of them I like this move most has it
stemmed the victory immediately with
Bishop to d3 destroying the defender of
the f7 pawn and believe it an order to
survive from this mess black has the
only nice choice namely Queen captures
g5
but even after this move quite opting
the winning advantage with Queen
captures defy night captors defy and the
moon Bishop captures g6 which gives him
a healthy pawn advantage the reason why
black cannot take this bishop because
after the following sequence Knight
captures g6 King to g7 rook captures f8
attacking the rook in the corner so
black responses force black has to take
this rook and after Knight takes and
King takes as we seen in the earlier
positions again and again we are getting
this with two pond and a rook against
two minor piece which is always going to
a difficult task when those connected
pawns are the distant past
so if Bishop captures G Phi is not
working how about King to g8 defending
this pond now we are going to follow a
game between two grandmasters wear white
responds with this very aggressive move
G for this mission doesn't have any
Square to go and the problem is he
cannot move as there's a mate on at 7 so
obviously after a long thing black come
up with this tactical idea Queen to b6
sacrificing the bishop in order to
create complication but as it turns out
that it only favors the white white
first of all captured the space
threatening mate on at 7 but black
reveal his strong with Queen catches d4
check and after rook to f2 his idea is
he wants to destroy this knight on d5
and after pawn takes it doesn't matter
whether black try to capture the piece
back or to play Bishop to c5 which
happens in the game
white response is very obvious and I
think you saw it right yep that
nasty mating net with ab six and how the
hell on earth black is going to save the
mate well I guess blacks idea was this
he wants to capture this rook and after
King 2h fun obviously there is no check
in this position but black has this
continuation namely Knight captures up
six and after pawn takes he played Queen
to g3 which not only protecting the g7
square but right now white can't even
take on g1 and if you look at this
position black is an exchange up so
isn't black survive the white attack
well of course not
after White's next reply there is a
forcing mate so before I show it to you
I want you to pause this video and find
out that killer mu which finish up the
black camp did you find it
let's see the MU is Bishop to d3 and
checkmate is in a vertical in the game
he tried Luke to d8 but after Queen
check came to a fade and Queen f7
actually black king is mated on the pole
probably the most critical response here
by a black is to play Bishop to a5 which
attacking the knight on e4 however white
has an equally strong move Queen to f4
attacking the bishop well it is wise to
get rid of as many as species to reduce
white attack so Bishop captures eful is
logical response afterwards white will
recapture it so at this point white has
a clear threat of Knight captures f7 so
accordingly black needs to stop it with
Knight to defy
and once again white will renew it with
Quinn to fi now if you open place Knight
to f6 or Queen to yet in this position
then white has a very nice smooth namely
rook to even and that rook will swing
across with the king side with rook to
e4 and resulting position are quite
favorable to the white camp so
accordingly the best response for the
black is to play Quinn to c8 attacking
the Queen well white would love to play
Knight to f7 but King to g7 spoil the
party so for a time being
White has to play Queen to h4 I got this
position against a feed a master in a
rapid game where my strong opponent
continue with Quinn to e6
so his idea is very simple the queen is
quickly coming on the King side to
rescue the king and also denying some
critical squares to the white camp
well no issues I continue with rook a to
even creating a x-ray on the King and
because right now there is no threat on
the Queen my opponent respond with rook
to the edge okay it's always good to
create a mating threat so I played
Bishop to d3 threatening a checkmate on
at 7 also there's a threat of Knight to
g6 and winning the Queen in some lines
so accordingly black played the only
move which keeps him in the game namely
Knight to f6 defending as well as
attacking on my queen and I calmly
played Queen 26 so now the threat is
very obvious Knight to g6 and the black
wing is a goner so he played Queen to d6
and roundabout here it looks like white
has no attack to speak of and there is
no great deal of compensation for losing
a piece however sometimes attacking
positions have some hidden resources and
this is not apart from it as
at this point White has a winning move
which kills the black on the spot before
I move on last time guys I want you to
pause this video and find out that
killer punch which finish off the black
okay then I hope you find this killer
blow boom hahahaha
what a move so why kiss sacrificing the
second bishop and black can't even touch
it
why let me show you why
if pawn captures g6 then the simplest is
Knight captures g6 check King to g8
Knight captures c7 check King to h8 and
now the winning blow Mike to fi
threatening to things the only logical
response is Queen to c7 but now rook to
e7 and in order to save the mate black
has to give the Queen and even after so
black position will not last for long in
the game my opponent wisely played Queen
to defy which once again safeguarding
the f7 but then I give him this ultimate
shock Bishop captures observable
attacking the Queen black responses
force he has to take the special
afterwards I deliver this winning
sequence Knight to g6 check King to g8
Knight captures c7 check black has to
take this night and after rook captures
e7 there are multiple ways the maid has
been threatened and only way to parry
this mates a queen to g5 counter
attacking the White Queen but white will
be more than happy to exchange a screen
has after Queen takes Knight takes and
the move who captures b7 in the final
position you can see that white has a
van rook for pawn and anyone who is good
at chairs can easily converted these
positions into the full point that's it
guys I hope you enjoy and learn this
tricky line in the Queens gambit
accepted from the white perspective once
you will try in your own game you will
see the real potential of this line and
in the tournament practice with the
clock ticking on the board and with some
great preparation you can definitely win
some nice points well thank you for
watching this video feel free to like
subscribe and comment on this and I'll
meet you in my next episode very soon
bye and take care